sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
Sie recht herzlich hier in der
rossauer-kaserne begrüßen zur heutigen
Pressekonferenz und zu Unterzeichnungen
einer Absichtserklärung gemeinsam mit
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Danner
und dem Präsidenten des
bundesfeuerwehrverbandes Herrn Robert
Mayer sehr geehrte Frau
Verteidigungsminister ich würde sie um
ihre Worte suchen
ja vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
der Medien
Leben schützen und Leben retten das
österreichische Bundesheer und die
Feuerwehr haben glaube ich sehr viele
gemeinsam nicht nur das die Frauen und
Männer bei der Organisationen Uniformen
tragen und körperliche Fitness und
Training und eine solide Ausbildung
vorweisen müssen um dann am Ende des
Tages schützen helfen und retten zu
können sondern ich glaube auch die
Eigenschaften mutdisziplin der Wille zu
helfen und die Bereitschaft auch unter
durchaus gefährlichen Rahmenbedingungen
bei jedem Wind und Wetter im Einsatz zu
stehen das verbindet unsere beiden
Organisationen jetzt bis jetzt war es
schon so ist es so dass die Feuerwehr
und des Bundes ja immer wieder
zusammenarbeitet bei Katastrophen Fällen
und da hatten wir ja in den vergangenen
Jahren tatsächlich sehr vieles vermehrt
zu bewältigen miteinander
von Naturkatastrophen
starke unwetterstürme Hochwasser und
Hagel und so wie die Feuerwehr steht
auch das österreichische Bundesheer oft
im Einsatz um eben der Bevölkerung bei
der Bewältigung von Naturkatastrophen
oder in Fällen von zum Beispiel auch
Waldbränden zu helfen was wir erleben
müssen leider Gottes erleben müssen ist
das Krisen und Katastrophen mehr werden
und was wir auch sehen ist dass es umso
wichtiger ist dass wir zusammenarbeiten
dass wir effizient zusammen wirken die
Behörden und Organisationen die eben mit
Sicherheitsaufgaben beschäftigt sind und
damit wir das gemeinsam im noch besser
tun können und auf mögliche
bevorstehende Katastrophen vorbereitet
sind haben wir uns entschlossen die
Zusammenarbeit zwischen dem Bundesheer
und der Feuerwehr in Form einer
Absichtserklärung zu manifestieren um
Synergien besser nutzen zu können um
Abläufe bei gemeinsamen einsetzen
effektiver gestalten zu können es sind
insgesamt zehn Punkte die diese
Erklärung umfasst da geht es um
regelmäßige gemeinsame Übungen zur
besseren Zusammenarbeit im Einzelfall
genauso wie um den strukturierten
Einsatz von Mitgliedern der Feuerwehr
beim grundwertdienst das heißt wir
wollen hinkünftig dass die
Grundwehrdiener bei den Pionieren bei
der ABC abwehrtruppe bei den feuerlösch
und brandschutzzügen auf unseren
Fliegerhorsten eingeteilt werden und was
wir auch noch machen werden ist dass die
Grundwehrdiener auch die Möglichkeit zur
Ausbildung vom c-führerschein bekommen
weiters werden wir gegenseitige Nutzung
der ausbildungsanlagen ermöglichen da
geht es um Ausbildungen zum Beispiel auf
gruppenübungsplätzen und
häuserkampfanlagen und um
feuerwehreinrichtungen wie
atemschutzstrecken die strukturierte
Zusammenarbeit im Bereich der
Waldbrandbekämpfung besonders mit den
Luftstreitkräften ist glaube ich das
mussten wir ja auch schon erleben ein
ganz ganz wichtiger Punkt
Erfahrungsaustausch aus Einsätzen und
Übungen soll künftig ebenfalls
strukturiert erfolgen auch der
Erfahrungsaustausch beim Einsatz von
Drohnen ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
warum betone ich immer wieder das Wort
das strukturiert ich glaube weil dies
der Weg zu einer professionellerin
Zusammenarbeit zwischen unser beider
Organisationen ist die Feuerwehr ist ein
ganz wichtiger Partner für uns für das
Bundesheer und es ist mir wirklich ein
Bedürfnis Danke zu sagen Danke zu sagen
dir Herr Präsident dass diese
Absichtserklärung und diese noch bessere
professionellere Zusammenarbeit möglich
geworden ist diese Kooperation zwischen
dem Verteidigungsministerium und dem
österreichischen
bundesfeuerwehrverband ist ein wichtiger
Schritt und bestehende Synergien durch
gemeinsame Ausbildungen Übungen und eine
verstärkte Zusammenarbeit der
Führungskräfte auch für die Zukunft zu
sichern und zu vertiefen denn jedes
Menschenleben das gerettet werden kann
zählt vielen Dank
ich würde nun das Wort an den
Präsidenten des bundesfeuerwehrverbandes
Herrn Robert Maier übergeben
ja und herzliches Dankeschön geschätzte
Frau Bundesministerin geschätzte Damen
und Herren ja es ist für uns auch ein
wichtiger Tag heute den wir hier begehen
können die Zusammenarbeit zu vertiefen
zu professionalisieren uns auszurichten
auf die neuen Herausforderungen die vor
uns liegen die durch unterschiedlichste
Einflüsse schaut man nur auf den
Klimawandel und deren Auswirkungen mit
denen wir zu rangekommen müssen hier ist
Zusammenarbeit und das näher
zusammenrücken das Gebot der Stunde und
ich denke wir bauen auf bestehende gute
Zusammenarbeit auf wollen das
intensivieren noch mehr
professionalisieren vor allem aber
weiterhin und stetig ausbauen auf
verschiedenen Ebenen und Frau
Bundesministerin ich bedanke mich gleich
vorweg sehr herzlich für diese
Möglichkeit dass unsere beiden
Organisationen hier noch ein engeres und
gemeinsames commitment finden
Zusammenarbeit ist der Schlüssel zum
Erfolg in all der Bewältigung unserer
einsatzaufgaben die wir tagtäglich in
den Feuerwehren absolvieren müssen ob es
die Berufsfeuerwehren sind ob es die
Betriebsfeuerwehren sind oder ob es die
Freiwilligen Feuerwehren sind und wir
arbeiten hier stets mit Partnern mit
anderen Einsatzorganisationen zusammen
vor allem aber dann wenn es auch um
Großschadenslagen geht dann ist
besonders auch die Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Bundesheer eine ganz essenzielle
Thematik auch für uns und so auch hier
nicht nur im Einsatzfall bestmöglich
zusammenzuarbeiten schon in der Einsatz
Vorbereitung in der Ausbildung in der
Übung
wollen wir hier auch eine einen neuen
Weg beschreiten und vor allem die
Einsatz Vorbereitung die Ausbildung
Übung das gemeinsame voneinander wissen
wie die Organisationen funktionieren und
laufen sind von großer Bedeutung wenn es
dann am Einsatzgeschehen gilt zusammen
zu arbeiten und hier sind in
Übereinkommen dass wir heute auch
unterzeichnen viele neue Aspekte dabei
wo wir das entsprechend intensivieren
und ausbauen können Expertise und
Erfahrungen zu nutzen Synergieeffekte
entsprechend zu nutzen und auszubauen
sind genauso enthalten und ich denke
hier sind viele Bereiche möglich auch
für uns möglich die wir dazu nutzen
können aber wir geben auch unser
Know-how entsprechend zurück und wenn
man rückwärts hinter uns schaut rechts
und links zwei Feuerwehrfahrzeuge der
einzige Unterschied würde sagen ist nur
die Farbe klarerweise oder dahinter
steckt eben viel Technik viel knochau
auch viel Expertise und hier sind viele
Synergieeffekte vorhanden die wir in der
Bekämpfung von den diversen
Schadenslagen auch
anwenden können und die
Herausforderungen
sie nehmen zu sie steigen stetig und wir
sehen es im Bereich der
Naturkatastrophen aber auch im Bereich
der ABC Abwehr also es gibt viele
Bereiche wo uns heute schon Themen
verbinden wo uns Herausforderungen
verbinden und dementsprechend möchten
wir uns hier sagen wirklich auch
gemeinsam auf diese Herausforderungen
konzentrieren und auch wirklich hier
gemeinsame Schritte in die Zukunft
setzen und es gibt so viele Themen die
uns auch in der Technisierung
beschäftigen ob das Robotik ist ob das
drohnentechnologien sind ja bis hin zur
dem ganz großen Thema natürlich der
Arbeitsgruppe der Waldbrand Bekämpfung
das Zusammenarbeiten mit den
Luftfahrzeugen eine bewährte Form aber
auch immer mehr von Bedeutung natürlich
ist bis hin dass wir auch als
österreichischer bundesfeuerwehrverband
und jetzt
durchaus auch strukturell aufgestellt
haben um im Bereich Wissenschaft und
Forschung hier näher uns mehr mit den
Themen auseinanderzusetzen und hier das
bereits begonnen auch erste
Synergieeffekte und
Zusammenarbeitsmodelle auch in dieser
Richtung aufzubauen das heißt der Bogen
ist ein großer ersparen sich
mittlerweile dann von Einsatzgeschehen
dass uns natürlich unser Kerngeschäft
ist bis hin auch zu Unterstützung der
Expertise durch die
jahresbekleidungsanstalt wenn es auch
darum geht und auch unsere neue
Bekleidung haben wir hier abgestimmt mit
den großen Erfahrungsschatz der hier
vorhanden ist also es gibt ganz ganz
viele Kontakte und vor allem auch in den
Bundesländern der unmittelbare Kontakt
dann zwischen den Militärkommandanten
und den
landesfeuerwehrkommandanten vor Ort
besteht ja auch eine sehr gute Basis in
der Zusammenarbeit ja auf das wollen wir
aufbauen und daher bin ich sehr dankbar
dass wir heute hier diese Unterschrift
zum einen setzen können aber vor allem
das was dahinter steckt hat Bedeutung
und dafür sind wir dankbar und ich freue
mich hier auf weitere tolle gemeinsame
Projekte die wir hier angehen können
danke schön
die Zusammenarbeit und das
Zusammenrücken wurde bereits
angesprochen und daher würde ich sie
einmal mehr ersuchen zusammen zurück
Rücken und den Kooperationsvertrag auch
zu unterzeichnen bevor wir dann
anschließend zu den Fragen übergehen
gibt es Fragen von Seiten der
Medienvertreter
nachdem es keine Fragen mehr gibt darf
ich die Pressekonferenz für beendet
erklären und lade die hier anwesenden
Gästen und gerne zu einem Rundgang
einerseits um das Löschfahrzeug der ABC
Abwehr und andererseits und das
Feuerwehrfahrzeug der Berufsfeuerwehr
Wien ein danke sehr
Auto